هؤلاء هم العلماء الذين قدموا للمملكه
المتحده انجازات المهمه خلال الجائحه وهذه
هي الاجهزه التي استخدموها لدراسه
التسجلات الجينيه لملايين مساحات اختبار
كورونا الان يريدون اخذ ما تعلموه من
فيروس كورونا وتطبيقه على فيروسات الجهاز
التنفسي الخطيره الاخرى مثل الانفلونزا
التي تضغط هذا الشتاء على الامر الصحيه
لانتقال هذه الفيروسات وتطورها على المدى
الطويل لذلك من خلال فهم المزيد من
خصائصها البيولوجيا نامل ان نتمكن من
مساعده العلماء الاخرين على ابتكار لقاحات
وايجاد علاجات جديده ولكن ايضا ينبغي
تفكير في كيفيه تدخلي لمنع انتشارها
لا يبدا المشروع في المختبر بل في ثلاث
حاويات شحن مبرده في الموقف السياره
تحتوي هذه الصناديق على ملايين العينات
المتبقيه من حملات اختبار كورونا لكنها لا
تزال مصدرا مهما بسبب جميع الفيروسات
الاخرى التي قد تحتويها تتمثل الخطه في
تصميم اختبار لاكتشاف جميع فيروسات الجهاز
التنفسي الاخرى التي كان الاشخاص يحمل لها
عندما تم مسحهم بحثا عن فيروس كورونا
واستخدام ذلك لانشاء برنامج مراقبه جديد
لمزيد من الاصابات
هو الذي جعل الجميع ان المنهجيه التي
لدينا للتشخيص التقليدي والمراقبه
التقليديه في مجال الامراض المعديه
الكبيره
تجاوزها الان من خلال قدرته على القيام
باشياء مع علم الجنو
ارتفعت معدلات الاصابه بفارس كورونا
والانفلونزا وفيروسات الاخرى هذا الشتاء
بالنسبه الشمالي من الكره الارضيه ما يضع
ضغطا كبيرا على المستشفيات في عدد من
البلدان ويقول العلماء ان المبادره في
المستقبل يمكن ان تجيب عن اسئله بشان تفشي
مثل هذه الفيروسات